Allen says as a father who actually took
my daughter to see this horrible Barbie
film I can assure anyone reading this
that the movie is far worse than
anything Matt Walsh could possibly
describe because he had the sense not to
sit through it I have never heard the
word patriarchy more in a film in my
life the film actually starts with them
literally saying that Barbie land was a
world where all the goals of feminism
have been realized then at the end of
the movie the dumb cans are put back in
their place and promised that with time
they could be in a place similar to that
of women in the real world far below
Barbie this is a feminist wet dream put
on film where all the men are stupid the
movie literally ceases to even be about
Barbie and morphs into a feminist
Manifesto before your eyes awful